NORMANDY ON THIS HISTORIC DAY.
>> LAURA: MR. PRESIDENT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY.
75TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE D-DAY
LANDING.
YOU'VE HAD BY ALL ACCOUNTS AN
INCREDIBLE TRIP.
WHAT LESSONS WILL YOU TAKE BACK
HOME AFTER THIS DAY AND YOUR
MEETING WITH THE QUEEN AND TRIP
TO IRELAND?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: FIRST, THE
MEETING WITH THE QUEEN WAS
INCREDIBLE.
I THINK I CAN SAY TO KNOW HER
BECAUSE I SAT WITH HER MANY
TIMES AND WE HAD AUTOMATIC
CHEMISTRY.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT FEELING,
IT'S A GOOD FEELING BUT SHE'S A
SPECTACULAR WOMAN.
AND THE PEOPLE I MET, I MET SO
MANY VETERANS.
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN IT, DAYS LIKE
NO ONE ELSE, AND THEY ARE JUST
REALLY INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
>> LAURA: FEELING THIS BEAUTIFUL
WEATHER, IT WAS RAINING LAST
NIGHT, THE WEATHER BROKE,
IMAGINING THE INVASION, 150,000
ALLIED TROOPS CLIMBING THE
CLIFFS, LANDING ON THESE SHORES,
WHAT'S GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THIS IS WEATHER
LIKE THEY DON'T NORMALLY HAVE.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE TODAY A
STORM.
IT'S A LITTLE LIKE THE INVASION
ITSELF.
THE WEATHER WAS A BIG FACTOR.
THEY DELAYED IT A DAY AND IT
WORKED OUT OKAY.
YOU LOOK AT THE WEATHER WE HAVE.
WE HAVE BEAUTIFUL WEATHER AND
IT'S BEEN THIS WAY WHEREVER I'VE
BEEN.
WE'VE BEEN NOW FOR 3 1/2 DAYS,
AND IT'S LIKE, I'M SAYING THIS,
IT'S PRETTY BEAUTIFUL BUT IT CAN
BE PRETTY ROUGH.
>> LAURA: AFTER HAVING MET ALL
OF THESE WORLD WAR II VETERANS,
THIS ENTIRE EXPERIENCE, WHAT DO
YOU TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
HISTORY AND OUR SHARED IDEALS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THAT THERE WAS
NEVER A MORE IMPORTANT BATTLE.
THERE WAS NEVER A MORE IMPORTANT
EVENT THAN THE EVENT 75 YEARS
AGO TODAY, THINK, THESE WERE
INCREDIBLE BRAVE PEOPLE WHO WERE
JUST BEING BLOWN UP, AND YOU
HAVE THE GRAVES ALL OVER.
THESE WERE PEOPLE THAT KNEW THEY
WERE GOING TO DIE.
IT WAS HORRENDOUS.
THE BRAVERY.
THE VALOR, WE'RE GIVING OUT
MEDALS TODAY.
WE'RE GIVING OUT MEDALS TO
CERTAIN PEOPLE IN CERTAIN
FAMILIES.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE TRUE, IN
TERMS OF WAR, IN TERMS OF
PROBABLY, YOU COULD ALSO SAY IN
TERMS OF PEACE, BECAUSE THIS LED
TO SOMETHING VERY SPECIAL, THIS
WAS A VERY, VERY HORRIFIC DAY
BUT IT WAS ALSO A VERY SPECIAL
DAY AND IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
HERE.
>> LAURA: TWO YEARS AGO, THE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS, FOREIGN
POLICY EXPERTS, WERE PREDICTING
THAT YOU WOULD FRACTURE NATO,
AMERICA WOULD BECOME
ISOLATIONISTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE EXPERTS
TODAY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT FAILED SO BADLY AND
I HAVEN'T REALLY GONE TO THEM.
I KNOW THEM.
I'VE READ THEM.
I'VE SEEN WHAT THEIR RESULT WAS
AND IT WAS TERRIBLE.
NATO WAS GOING DOWN AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MONEY COMING INTO
NATO FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS IT
WAS ESCALATING DOWN AND NOW IT'S
LIKE A ROCKET SHIP UP.
SECRETARY SALLEN BERG HAS BEEN
MAYBE TRUMPEST BIGGEST FAN.
HE SAID WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP
MAYBE THERE WOULD BE NO NATO.
WE'VE GOT CONDITION OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE THEY ARE
STARTING TO PAY BECAUSE IT GOT
TO A POINT WHERE WE WERE PAYING
SO MUCH.
I THINK WE WERE REALLY PAYING
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED PERCENT OF
NATURE TOE.
WE WERE PAYING TO PROTECT ALL
THESE NATIONS AND IT JUST WASN'T
FAIR.
I TOLD THE HEADS OF COUNTRIES,
IT'S NOT FAIR.
THE U.N. POSSIBLY DOESN'T EVEN
BENEFIT.
YOU COULD MAKE THE CASE,
CERTAINLY IN THIS AGE, WE'RE NOT
BENEFITING, CERTAIN NOT LIKE
THEM.
THEY PAID OVER A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS MORE TOWARD THEIR
DEFENSE.
THAT'S MONEY WE DON'T HAVE TO
PAY.
>> LAURA: -- WAS PRAISING YOU
YESTERDAY FOR THE BURDEN
SHARING, BASICALLY ABOUT TIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: SHE WAS SO NICE
BUT THEY ARE ALL SAYING IT AND
THEY ARE STEPPING UP.
I WOULD SAY GERMANY HAS NOT
STEPPED UP MUCH.
THEY ARE PAYING 1%, THEY SHOULD
BE PAYING MUCH MORE.
THINK OF IT.
1%, SO WE PROTECT GERMANY AND
THEN GERMANY TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
US ON TRADE.
I WAS WITH MERKEL A LOT
YESTERDAY.
I LIKE HER A LOT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK WE DON'T
HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP, WE DO,
AND SHE EVEN SMILES, WHEN I SAY,
LOOK, TOUGH TO PAY, SHE SAID,
FOR YEARS, THEY GOT AWAY WITH
THIS AND IT'S UNFAIR AND THEY
ARE NOT GETTING AWAY WITH IT.
>> LAURA: WHAT ABOUT HER DIG
WHEN YOU WERE AT HARVARD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WHAT DID SHE
SAY?
>> I WANT TO WISH THIS WISH WITH
YOU, TEAR DOWN THE WALLS OF
IGNORANCE AND NARROW-MINDEDNESS
FOR NOTHING STAYS AS IT IS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: SHE HAS TO SAY
WHAT SHE HAS TO SAY.
SHE TOOK A PRETTY TOUGH ELECTION
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO.
BUT I LIKE HER.
I GET ALONG WITH HER BUT I SAID
YOU HAVE TO PAY AND MOST OF THE
NATIONS ARE NOW EITHER CURRENT
OR VERY CLOSE TO CURRENT AND
THAT'S A TREMENDOUS -- IT'S OVER
A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
>> LAURA: MEXICO TARIFFS, BIG
NEWS BACK HOME, SOME SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE A LITTLE WORRIED
ABOUT THIS, ESPECIALLY ECONOMIC
EFFECTS.
WHAT MUST MEXICO DO?
WHAT CAN THEY DO TO STEM THIS
MASSIVE TIDE, 140,000 PEOPLE IN
MAY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WHEN YOU'RE THE
PIGGY BANK THAT EVERYBODY STEALS
AND ROBS FROM AND THEY DECEIVE
YOU, LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
FOR 25 YEARS, TARIFFS ARE A
BEAUTIFUL THING.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL WORD IF YOU
KNOW HOW TO USE THEM PROPERLY.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD LOVE WHAT I'M
DOING BECAUSE, I DO TARIFFS IN
TWO PHASES.
NUMBER ONE, IT'S GREAT TO
NEGOTIATE WITH BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE TARIFF # COMING
INTO THE UNITED STATES, AND
NUMBER TWO, YOU CAN MAKE A
FORTUNE BECAUSE ALL THE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> LAURA: ISN'T THIS CONGRESS'S
FAULT, SO WHY DOES IT SEEM LIKE
MEXICO IS BEARING THE BRUNT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY ARE
LETTING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WALK
UP THROUGH THEIR COUNTRY AND
THEY SHOULDN'T LET ANYBODY WALK
UP THROUGH THEIR COUNTRY.
FRANKLY, WE SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE
TO HAVE BORDER PATROL.
BORDER PATROL IS DOING
INCREDIBLY.
THEY APPREHENDED OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE --
>> LAURA: 140,000 IN MAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, AND BY THE WAY THAT'S NOT
EVEN CLOSE TO A RECORD BECAUSE
IF YOU GO BACK 13, 14 YEARS AGO,
IT WAS CRAZY NUMBERS, BUT I
DON'T WANT THIS.
I WANT PEOPLE TO COME IN
LEGALLY.
WE WANT THE PEOPLE THAT WE WANT
AND I WANT -- WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
ANYBODY, THEY SHOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO WALK THROUGH MEXICO AND NOW
I'VE TOLD MEXICO, IF YOU DON'T
STOP THIS ONSLAUGHT THIS
INVASION, PEOPLE GET ANGRY WHEN
I USE THE WORD INVASION, PEOPLE
LIKE NANCY PELOSI, THAT
HONESTLY, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE HELL THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I WATCHED HER, SHE WAS SAYING,
WE HAVE TO PROTECT MEXICO, WE
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF MEXICO.
LOOK, I'M DEALING WITH MEXICO
RIGHT NOW, THEY SEND IN $500
BILLION WORTH OF DRUGS.
THEY KILL A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
THEY RUIN A MILLION FAMILIES.
EVERY YEAR.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, THAT'S REALLY
AN INVASION WITHOUT THE GUNS.
>> LAURA: ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
HOW THIS MIGHT AFFECT THE USMCA,
ANOTHER HISTORIC TRADE --
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY NEED US.
THEY STOLE 32% OF OUR CAR
BUSINESS WITH NAFTA.
THE STOOP ITTEST DEAL, ONE OF
THE STUPIDEST DEAL OF OUR TIME.
THEY STOLE 32,000 -- THEY HAVE
32%.
>> LAURA: THEY ARE AN IMPORTANT
ALLY OF THE UNITED STATES?
ONE OF OUR MOST IMPORTANT
TRADING PARTNERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: FINE.
AND YET THEY SEND IN $500
BILLION WORTH OF DRUGS.
WE'LL NEVER DO THAT KIND OF
TRADE.
THEY SEND IN DRUGS, ILLEGAL
DRUGS, $500 BILLION, A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE KILLED,
DEAD, EVERY YEAR FROM WHAT COMES
THROUGH OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWING
ANGLE."
NOW MORE OF MY EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> LAURA: NANCY PELOSI AS WE
WERE WALKING UP TO THE STAGE
EARLIER, SHE SAID SOME PRETTY
HARSH THINGS OVER THE LAST 24
HOURS, LEAKED OUT FROM HER
CAUCUS.
I DON'T WANT IMPEACHMENT, I WANT
HIM IN PRISON.
MEANING YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I THINK SHE'S A
DISGRACE.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S A TALENTED
PERSON.
I'VE TRIED TO BE NICE TO HER
BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO
HAVE GOTTEN SOME DEALS DONE.
SHE'S INCAPABLE OF DOING DEALS.
SHE'S A NASTY,VIN DICK ACTIVE
HOBBS PERSON, MUELLER REPORT
CAME OUT, IT WAS A DISASTER FOR
THEM.
THEY THOUGHT THEIR GOOD FRIEND
BOBBY MUELLER WAS GOING TO GIVE
THEM A GREAT REPORT AND HE CAME
OUT WITH A REPORT WITH 13
HORRIBLE, ANGRY DEMOCRATS WHO
WERE TOTALLY BIASED AGAINST ME.
A COUPLE OF THEM WORKED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY THEN ADDED FIVE MORE, ALSO
DEMOCRATS.
WITH ALL OF THAT, 2 1/2 YEARS,
THINK OF IT, FROM BEFORE I EVEN
GOT ELECTED, THEY HAVE BEEN
GOING AFTER ME, AND THEY HAVE
NOTHING.
>> LAURA: DO YOU FIND IF HE
TESTIFIES, YOU SAID BEFORE YOU
DIDN'T CARE?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: HE MADE SUCH A
FOOL OF HIMSELF.
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T REPORT IS THE
LETTER HE HAD TO DO TO
STRAIGHTEN OUT HIS TESTIMONY
BECAUSE HIS TESTIMONY WAS WRONG.
BUT NANCY PELOSI, I CALL HER
NERVOUS NANCY, SHE DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
NANCY PELOSI IS A DISASTER,
OKAY?
SHE'S A DISASTER, AND LET HER DO
WHAT SHE WANTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK THEY ARE IN BIG TROUBLE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
KIND OF CRIMES THAT WERE
COMMITTED, I DON'T NEED ANY MORE
EVIDENCE AND I GUESS FROM WHAT
I'M HEARING THERE IS A LOT OF
EVIDENCE COMING IN.
AND THEN ASK NANCY, WHY IS HER
DISTRICT HAVE DRUGS AND NEEDLES
ALL OVER THE PLACE?
IT'S THE MOST DISGUSTING THING
WHAT SHE'S ALLOWED TO HAVE
HAPPEN TO HER DISTRICT, WITH
NEEDLES, DRUG ADDICTS, PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STREETS, ON THE SIDEWALKS, SHE
OUGHT TO FOCUS ON THAT BECAUSE
SHE'S A DISASTER AND SHE MADE A
STATEMENT, IT WAS A HORRIBLE,
NASTY VICIOUS STATEMENT, WHILE
I'M OVERSEAS, NOW, HAVE I MADE
ANY STATEMENT ABOUT ANYBODY IT
WOULD BE LIKE, WHY WOULD HE DO
THAT WHEN HE'S OVERSEAS?
SHE'S A TERRIBLE PERSON, AND I
TELL YOU, HER NAME, IS NERVOUS
NANCY BECAUSE SHE'S A NERVOUS
WRECK.
>> LAURA: ON TUESDAY JOE BIDEN
ONCE AGAIN DOWNPLAYED THE CHINA
THREAT AT ONE OF HIS TOWN
HALL --
PRESIDENT TRUMP: HE DOESN'T GET
IT.
>> WE'RE IN A POSITION WHERE WE
HAVE THE MOST AGILE VENTURE
CAPITALIST IN THE WORLD.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE THE BAD
GUYS.
WE'RE THE BEST AT DOING IT.
OUR WORKERS ARE LITERALLY THREE
TIMES AS PRODUCTIVE AS WORKERS
IN THE FAR EAST.
I MEAN, EXCUSE ME IN ASIA.
AND THEY ARE THREE TIMES
PRODUCTIVE.
WHAT ARE WE WORRIED ABOUT?
>> LAURA: HOW HAPPY WOULD YOU
BE, PRESIDENT TO HAVE JOE BIDEN
BE THE NOMINEE?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: HE WANTS HIM.
HE WANTS HIM.
LOOK, WE'RE TAKING IN TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE HAD A 3.2 GDP FIRST QUARTER,
ALWAYS LESS THAN 1%.
IT ALWAYS THE WORST QUARTER.
3.2.
A POINT AND A HALF ABOVE
SCHEDULE.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE SO MUCH MONEY IS COMING
IN FROM CHINA.
WE NEVER TOOK IN ANY MONEY FROM
CHINA.
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE SECRET.
THAT'S ONLY A LITTLE TINY PIECE
BECAUSE THE BIG ONE IS YET TO
COME.
WE HAVE $325 BILLION THAT I
HAVEN'T EVEN TAXED YET, AND THEY
HAVE ALREADY SPENT ALL OF THEIR
WEAPONS.
THEY HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THEY
CAN.
I TELL YOU, THE GREATEST PEOPLE,
THE FARMERS.
OUR PATRIOT FARMERS, THEY ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT, AND, YOU
REMEMBER THIS ABOUT THE FARMERS,
FOR 15 YEARS, BEFORE I GOT HERE,
EVERYTHING WAS COMING DOWN.
SO THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THE FARMERS ARE GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST BENEFICIARIES BUT
THESE ARE PATRIOTS.
PEOPLE THAT SAY, THE PRESIDENT
IS RYE, AND IF I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH A LITTLE SHORT TERM
PROBLEM IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
LISTEN TO THOSE INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE BACK THERE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO AMAZING, AND
WHAT THEY DON'T REALIZE IS THAT,
I'M HOLDING THEM UP BECAUSE OF
THIS INTERVIEW BUT THAT'S
BECAUSE IT'S YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR RATING.
>> LAURA: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HE AND PRESIDENT PUTIN SAT DOWN
YESTERDAY ANNOUNCING NEW TRADE
DEALS, TALKING ABOUT THEIR
CLOSER, WARMER RELATIONSHIP.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE YOU DID WANT
TO HAVE A BETTER RELATIONSHIP IF
POSSIBLE WITH RUSSIA AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR TERM.
IS THAT OUT THE WINDOW NOW?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
IT'S HURT BY THE PHONY
WITCH-HUNT.
I COULD HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH RUSSIA.
AGAIN, WE HAVE WHAT EVERYONE
WANTS.
I BUILT AN ECONOMY THAT'S
INCREDIBLE.
WE'RE UP $14 TRILLION IN VALUE.
LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
STOCK MARKET, AND THIS IS
DESPITE THE FEDERAL RESERVE THAT
FRANKLY SHOULD HAVE HAD LOWER
INTEREST RATES.
NOW, THERE IS A SAFETY NET
THAT'S GOOD AND MORE
CONSERVATIVE, BUT IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE ALL OF THESE INTEREST RATE,
YOU KNOW, WHO THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO RAISE INTEREST RATES?
BUT IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT, WE
WOULD BE -- 5.2 AND THE STOCK
MARKET WOULD BE UP 10,000 POINTS
MORE BUT NOW WE HAVE A VERY
CONSERVATIVE APPROACH.
WE'VE CREATED TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN VALUE, AND, BY THE
WAY, CHINA HAS LOST TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN VALUE.
IF SOMEBODY ELSE, LET'S SAY THE
OPPONENT, WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
EVEN BEEN ALLOWED TO RUN, SHE
HAPPENS TO BE A CROOKED PERSON,
SO HER NAME WAS VERY
APPROPRIATE, BUT IF SHE EVER
WON, OUR, I WOULD SAY CHINA
RIGHT NOW WOULD BE FAR AHEAD OF
THE UNITED STATES.
JUST THINK OF IT.
CHINA WOULD HAVE BEEN -- WE'RE
NOW SO FAR AHEAD OF CHINA, IT'S
NOT EVEN A CONTEST.
>> LAURA: WHAT YOU COULD DO TO
UNITE THE COUNTRY IN A TIME OF
GREAT POLARIZATION?
WHAT ELSE COULD DO YOU?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I THINK SUCCESS
SHOULD UNITE THE COUNTRY, BUT
I'LL TELL YOU, THE MORE
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE COME, THE MORE
ANGRY PEOPLE LIKE NANCY PELOSI,
WHO DOESN'T HAVE WHAT IT TAKES,
WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON,
THEY GET ANGRY.
AN EXAMPLE IS MEXICO.
I SAID, WE'RE GOING TO PUT
TARIFFS ON BECAUSE WE WANT YOU
TO HELP US BECAUSE THEY WON'T
PAY US ANY LEGISLATION IN
CONGRESS AND I HAVE SENATORS AND
OTHERS AND PELOSI COMING OUT
SAYING, OH, HOW HORRIBLE.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS THEY ARE
HURTING THE DEAL.
THEY SHOULD BE SAYING, WE'RE
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE'LL DO WHATEVER HE WANTS TO DO
AND MEXICO WOULD FOLD LIKE AN
UMBRELLA.
AND NOW I HAVE THESE PEOPLE, AND
I'M SAYING THERE ARE SOME
REPUBLICANS, TOO, THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES, BUT WE
HAVE PELOSI, WE HAVE CHUCK
SCHUMER, WHO IS A DISASTER, BY
THE WAY, A TOTAL POLITICAL JERK,
BUT WE HAVE SCHUMER, AND ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE, THEY COME OUT AND
THEY TALK ABOUT TARIFFS, OR
THIS -- THEY HURT MY
NEGOTIATION, BECAUSE I GO INTO
THE ROOM WITH THE MEXICANS, I'M
ASKING THEM FOR EVERYTHING, AND,
BY THE WAY, IF THEY DON'T DO IT,
I'M PUTTING THE TRAFRS ON AND
WE'LL MAKE A FORTUNE.
ONE THING WITH THE TARIFFS, WHEN
THOSE TARIFFS GO ON COMPANIES
WILL START MOVING BACK.
COMPANIES WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY TOOK 32% OF OUR CAR
INDUSTRY.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE PLANTS
WILL MOVE BACK INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> LAURA: ARE YOU GOING TO GET A
DEAL WITH CAN CHINA?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I'LL DEFINITELY
GET A DEAL WITH CHINA.
THEY WANT TO MAKE A DEAL NOW.
WHAT THEY DID WAS VERY BAD.
WE HAD A DEAL AND THEY TRIED TO
RENEGOTIATE.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
>> LAURA: WHAT DO YOU PRAY FOR
WHEN YOU PRAY FOR THIS COUNTRY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: PEACE.
REALLY PEACE.
AND WE BUILT UP OUR MILITARY,
WE'VE BUILT UP OUR WEALTH, OUR
COUNTRY IS IN SUCH GREAT SHAPE
RIGHT NOW, IRAN IS IN A MUCH
DIFFERENT POSITION THAN THEY
WERE 2 1/2 YEARS AGO.
2 1/2 YEARS AGO, IRAN WAS A
DISASTER FOR US.
NOW THEY HAVE GOT PROBLEMS.
LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY.
THEY AREN'T THE SAME COUNTRY.
NORTH KOREA, NO NUCLEAR TESTS, I
HAVE A GOOD -- WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
CHINA WANTS TO MAKE A DEAL.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO MAKE A DEAL.
WE'RE THE BEST.
WE'RE THE STRONGEST.
THERE IS NO ONE EVEN CLOSE.
>> LAURA: MR. PRESIDENT,
FINALLY, DID YOU OR DID YOU NOT,
THE WORLD WANTS TO KNOW, FIST
PUMP WITH THE QUEEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: DI NOT, BUT
THERE ARE KNOWS WHO SAY THEY
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE CONVEN
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE QUNVEN
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE QUEEEN
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE QUEENN
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE QUEEN HAVE A
BETTER TIME OR MORE ANIMATED
TIME.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHO THE OTHER
PEOPLE WERE AT THE TABLE.
NEVER SPOKE TO THEM.
>> LAURA: ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP
THE CONVERSATION GOING WITH HER?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: YES, I AM,
SHE'S A SPECTACULAR WOMAN, AN
INCREDIBLE WOMAN.
>> LAURA: MR. PRESIDENT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, GOOD LUCK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: TAKE CARE OF
YOURSELF.
>> LAURA: BY THE WAY, SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD A RED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPOSEDLY HELD
UP THE ENTIRE D-DAY CEREMONY IN
ORDER TO DO THIS INTERVIEW WITH
ME.
THAT'S PATENTLY FALSE.
FAKE NEWS.
WE HEARD THE MACRON -- OUR CUE
TO END THE INTERVIEW IS WHEN WE
HEARD THE MACRON HELICOPTER.
THE INTERVIEW ENDED BEFORE
MACRON LANDED.